in a war zone acts of courage take many
different shapes
lud Miller has a son who's a soldier
defending the nearby town of bakmut
um
as a volunteer she first delivers Aid to
troops outside the town
then with a quick prayer Luke Miller and
her team head in
we follow
looks deceptively calm from a distance
[Music]
but a bloody battle is Raging here as
Russia tries to bombard the town into
submission after repeated defeats
elsewhere
most of the people who lived here have
fled
we pull up in a residential area
the threat of artillery rounds is high
so the team Works fast
those who still live here either don't
want to leave or can't because of age or
illness
basic supplies like these are vital
she says there are residents in this
basement
try to speak to them
but no one's home
we head next door crunching on shattered
glass
don't pretend
a man inside doesn't want to talk and
says no one's around
time to move
we spot a small crowd to talk to while
lud Miller heads further into town
what is life like here in Buck moose
foreign
there's no water there's no heat the
buildings are shattered and there's a
danger of death at any moment
they all want simple stoves to heat
their homes
shows us a shrapnel wound on his head
with the booms getting louder we pull
out
danger can strike at any moment here
[Music]
shrapnel from the incoming round only
just missed the car in front
a crude reminder of the reality and the
randomness of War
[Music]
back with ludmiller the team Braves more
explosions to reach people in the center
of town
they filmed some of the destruction
along the way before stopping to give
out Aid
[Music]
s
you can hear the danger and the
desperation
Drone footage shows the devastation in
the area around bakmut after months of
fighting now even some of those who'd
refuse to leave the town are going
safely out ludmiller is about to reunite
one mother with her son who was
evacuated from bakmut without her last
week
the six-year-old doesn't know his mother
has finally agreed to follow
what's yours now
[Music]
at just 22 Katarina hadn't wanted to
leave her flat but had allowed Luke
Miller to take her child to the city of
denipro
she then changed her mind about staying
and was evacuated by other volunteers
with just the clothes on their backs
they're moving to a shelter
it'll still be tough but at least
they're together
Deborah Hayne Sky News in eastern
Ukraine